en même temps moi j'ai revendu ma tête
depuis longtemps donc ça va dominique
farrugia et vas-y fais toi plaisir
j'adore cette coupe deux buts contre
gagne je savais que ça allait venir
aujourd'hui jeudi jour où l'état a nommé
ses mots ses mots c'est bon j'ai roux
fait la même après demain il faut être
pour monter sur un tabouret j'ai failli
mourir dans ce combat des jeux tabouret
c'est une tannée décorateur de télé
réfléchi en tabouret de bar les mets ma
grève que dans les bars à [ __ ] c'est
moi aussi réseau et chantal les fautes
en relais qu on l'équipe est très
content de vous rencontrer
moi je vous connaissais je peux vous
embrasser ainsi j'aime beaucoup ce que
vous faites ce que vous voudrez je suis
mariée depuis 13 ans ouais je sais mais
moi la déco la comédie je t'ai connu à
voir la comédie j'étais patron comédie
et l' énorme il a fallu neuf avaient
toutes les meufs vous les péchés unis
c'était facile j'avais la chaîne qui
marchait donc voilà ah ouais ben voilà
il y avait ces mamans vous a dit il faut
que deviennent patrons
très bonne gueule il que les mof et
tétouan les comics mais parce que ce
n'est pas trop elle le qui fait vraiment
déçu tout amour aux riches dominique va
falloir vous parler un moment jean
michel mr et de l'irimep que l'humour
n'est pas sa première can you tic ça
commence à venir dans 7 8 ans il devrait
être bon bonjour tu l'avais tellement
réclamé sur twitter je vous jure que
c'est vrai j'ai vu la dernière fois et
sur twitter tombe mais pourquoi
dominique qui revient pas pourquoi
dominique y revient pas et basket a pas
assez d'argent masculin mignon mignon
ces changements y tenons vous préférez
romantique vous préférez maintenant
avant bah c'est un bel homme bresser
extrait l'eau on lui dit pas assez
on peut débuter la rentrée sous une
seule une heure la bonne humeur avec le
retour mais moi je vais pas me faire
quand vous le dis vous dit pardonnez moi
je faisais vous en prie j'ai beaucoup de
sympathie pour vous ton de voix me fait
tellement rire mais même à la télé ça me
fait rêver
je risque d'avoir des fous rires eh bien
je suis désolé je prends ça comme un
compliment vous savez mais vraiment je
demande pardon m haies et j'adorais en
même temps moi j'ai vendu ma tête depuis
longtemps donc ça va ça a très bien
marché en audience on va suivre ça et
vous nous donnerez les audiences à
semaine prochaine les événements
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]